y justamente en directo ahora vamos a
Caracas la capital venezolana porque
Naciones Unidas publicó un informe en el
que denuncia que decenas de personas han
sido Víctimas de torturas y maltratos en
centros de detención de los servicios de
inteligencia venezolanos el texto es
conclusión del trabajo de la misión
independiente de la ONU para Venezuela y
asegura que tanto el servicio
bolivariano de inteligencia nacional
como la dirección general de
contrainteligencia militar son parte de
un mecanismo diseñado para ejecutar el
plan gubernamental de reprimir a la
oposición y apuntalarse en el poder el
segundo tema es el encuentro de los
presidentes Gustavo Petro y Nicolás
Maduro que se producirá este lunes en
medio de la apertura oficial de la
frontera entre ambas naciones conectamos
con Daniela Zambrano corresponsal de
Franz 24 en Caracas Daniela que
conclusiones arroja el informe que
reacciones Se han generado
una de las principales conclusiones que
arrojó este informe es que el estado
venezolano utiliza el servicio de
inteligencia para reprimir a la
disidencia y a la oposición esto incluye
crímenes de lesa humanidad también
torturas y delitos sexuales señalando a
los órganos del servicio bolivariano de
inteligencia Y de la dirección de
country inteligencia militar siendo los
principales responsables otra de las
conclusiones es que los funcionarios de
estos organismos no actuaron de manera
independiente y aislada sino por el
contrario respondían a órdenes directas
de altos funcionarios del gobierno
señalando directamente al presidente
Nicolás Maduro es estar al frente de
este plan para reprimir a la oposición
también registró el informe las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidas en la zona del Arco mi dinero
en el estado Bolívar en la que la
población es víctima de los
enfrentamientos entre cuerpos de
seguridad del estado y grupos
irregulares por el control del Oro llama
la atención además que señalara a
directamente al presidente Nicolás
Maduro también al director de la dije
SIM al director del servicio bolivariano
inteligencia Y al vicepresidente del
partido socialista Unido de Venezuela
diosdado cabello directamente como
responsables hubo reacciones por parte
de organizaciones no gubernamentales
derechos humanos y también de dirigentes
políticos opositores que coinciden en
que este informe el tercero de la misión
internacional independiente de
determinación de hechos de Venezuela de
la ONU que esto no hace sino ratificar
las denuncias que ellos han hecho en los
últimos años con respecto a crímenes de
lesa humanidad recordemos que este
informe recoge denuncias desde el año
2014 se espera que el próximo 26 de
septiembre sea presentado ante el
Consejo de Seguridad derechos humanos de
la ONU
Daniela qué cesado del desplazamiento de
maduro a la frontera con Colombia Cómo
se realizaría el encuentro con Petro
al momento no había una confirmación por
parte del presidente Nicolás Maduro de
que vaya a asistir a esta reapertura de
la frontera entre Colombia y Venezuela
el próximo 26 de septiembre sin embargo
este martes estuvo en Caracas el
ministro de transporte de Colombia
Guillermo Reyes quien dijo que esperaba
que el próximo 26 de septiembre pudiera
saber un encuentro entre ambos
mandatarios en un punto aún sin
determinar pero que podría ser el puente
Simón Bolívar sin embargo repetimos esto
no ha sido confirmado públicamente por
el presidente Nicolás Maduro ni por
ninguna autoridad en Venezuela se espera
que se reanude el paso fronterizo por el
puente Simón Bolívar y también por el
puente Francisco de Paula Santander y
que más adelante se reanuda el paso por
los otros puentes Nicolás Maduro hablaba
de una reapertura de frontera progresiva
para llegar a una apertura total cuando
las condiciones estuvieran garantizadas
recordemos que estaba cerrado el paso
vehicular desde el año 2015 se tiene
previsto que miércoles haya una
videoconferencia entre los ministros de
comercio y economía de Colombia y la
vicepresidenta de Venezuela delcy
Rodríguez para afinar detalles y también
ha habido contactos entre el ministro de
defensa de Colombia y su homólogo
venezolano para lo que tiene que ver con
la materia de seguridad para el próximo
25 de septiembre un día antes de la
reapertura de la frontera entre ambos
países también está previsto un
encuentro entre representantes del
Congreso de Colombia y representantes de
la asamblea nacional de Venezuela que
preside Jorge Rodríguez